ma pulsano a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
questo nuovissimo video di mp ragazzi
oggi facciamo un episodio veramente
strano ma strano forte ho visto che c'è
una persona quello che fai gameplay e in
base a cosa succede fa venire il video è
affatto una roba sua e gli scavi è
piaciuto un sacco della serie quando
sanguinò finisce il video io volevo fare
la stessa cosa farò anche quella del
sanguinare più avanti però sul morire
quindi questo è un video di happy meals
ma se muoio finisce il video che è
veramente strana come cosa voglio
assolutamente farlo però se muoio
finisce vino quindi devo stare veramente
attenti iniziava con un rock swing
allora rock swing ko
let's go sono vivo tutto bene tutto bene
ma perché veramente se sanguini proprio
ma neanche un secondo non duro neanche
venti secondi c'è veramente orribile
così è già qualcosa
teoricamente c'è un altro sono vivo era
un face to face
zitti zitti che mi sta impegnando vi
prego fatemi vincere che è veramente sto
sudando tantissimo so io sono vivo ecco
se fosse stato sanguinato c'è ogni volta
che san guido sarebbe già finito il
video ma tranquilli non c entrano dentro
resisti che mori porca vacca perfetto
per questo progetto non c'è più le
braccia ricacciano uno solo e nero
finché ne servono due fidatevi
ho solo un razzo ti prego devi resistere
non morire lo rivendo ti fa staccare il
braccio la tipa strana e blush ti prego
[Musica]